[Music]
When I was a kid, when I was talking about my grandpa,
5060 was my grandpa. I'm
really surprised that he's still in his 80s and everyone is still doing it.
[Music]
Since last year,  I can play 80 leagues, so
this is becoming more and more common over the years.I do
n't think it's a typical example of someone being able to do something like this in an aging society, like the structure of Japan's society.That's
already fun.After all, it's all about
playing.  It's fun in and of itself, and
even after it's over, you can still have various conversations, and you can
drink tea and have conversations in various places, and I think it's
really nice that you want to drink and have a lot of conversations.
[Music]